Okay, hello, everybody. We are recording and this is our Zoom call for Halloween even in 2018. So we're going to go over some questions that people had and we'll open it up for questions.
So first of all, we're going to talk about what will skim through this quite quickly, because I have a presentation on NF, Capabata, nuclear factor, Capabata, nuclear factor, Capabata is an immune regulator in our body and uncontrolled. It can be a stimulator for cancer. So it's something that we want to keep in control.
It is, it's a part of our normal immune response. And this is the danger of, okay, well, we want a good immune response with cancer.
And nuclear factor, Capabata is a part of the immune response when we want to upregulate that. But this is what's upregulated in chronic inflammation. And there's a difference between a chronic inflammatory state, which can lead to cancer.
And acute inflammation, which can be the result of an acute immune response. It's the different immune cells that are stimulated, the different cytokines that are stimulated in those two.
Though they sound the same, they're kind of opposing factors in the immune system.
So nuclear factor, Capabata, increases cell survival proliferation, invasion, which has to do with cells getting into other tissues, which is a testicist, right here at angiogenesis, angiogenesis, angiolines, blood vessel,
so this is growth of new blood vessels. So nuclear factor, Capabata is one of those things that is, remember when I always say there's nothing in our body that has made it our body that is either inherently good or inherently bad, it's the balance, or we could say imbalance that can hurt us.
And especially if we have a certain disease going on. So nuclear factor, Capabata, you'd almost want to be upregulated if you were not dealing with with cancer.
You would upregulate nuclear, normal things like exercise, upregulate nuclear factor, Capabata, and stimulate angiogenesis, which is what you want around your heart, and you want the growth of new blood vessels that we want, cell survival and proliferation.
But when we have cancer, we don't want overall cell survival, cancer cell survival, and angiogenesis, which is growing blood vessels into a growing tuber also, and we certainly don't want the testicist.
So depending on what condition we're dealing with, we certainly don't want to upregulate at a Capabata.
And it is a problem with chronic inflammation. Well, things that upregulate Capabata is stress. I mean, you think of it.
When we are under stressful conditions, we need to increase cell survival, we might need to increase angiogenesis that could help the survival of you as a body.
We have chronic infection, obesity, addiction can all upregulate NF, Capabata, upregulates these different immune molecules, these are cytokines, and can cause issues.
So those are some things we want to keep in control.
Well, carcubin, the nutrient that is in tuberic, is probably the best way to downregulate nuclear factor, Capabata.
All these other things will help decrease NF, Capabata as well, but carcubin by far there's the most studies on that will help with that.
And another question that we had to commit was about IGF1, and the person said you talk about IGF1 quite often, could you remind us what IGF1 is.
Well, there's even supplements of IGF1. So again, is IGF1 is a chemical that's produced in your body that's called insulin growth factor 1.
It's not a growth hormone, it's different than a growth hormone, but it is a growth factor when it comes to cell proliferation and cell survival.
So if I was working out and I wanted to increase my cell survival and increase angiogenesis to my heart and tissue, well you might think about taking IGF1 capsules.
And personally, I would never take IGF1 capsules because everybody probably has some kids or cells in their body, so I wouldn't want to upregulate IGF1 exogenously, maybe taking something that's going to stimulate IGF1.
There's different growth hormone supplements that are on the market for that sake.
So many times bodybuilders, people that are trying to work it out for athletics or something like that will take supplements like this to help build muscle cells to build tissue cells. Well, that can be very dangerous if you have kids are going on.
Remember this slide here, we spoke about this often, that IGF1 upregulates MTOR.
So MTOR is the growth mechanism in our body that is upregulated through a lot of different stimulation.
Now in a sense, again, this is not a bad thing, you need growth upregulation if you injure your tissue or something so that you heal that tissue.
But we don't want to be constantly stimulated MTOR if we have a diagnosis of cancer.
And some of the things that are what are the things that upregulate MTOR is IGF1 increase.
So we have to be careful with that. Where do we get IGF1 increase? Well, this chart talks about dairy, but we'll talk about some other things as well.
So we want to do regulate IGF1. So exogenous sources of IGF1 and other growth hormone factors are provide growth hormone in dairy products.
So DUD or GANIC dairy products could have a BGH hormone in it. That's a strong upregulation of growth hormone and IGF1.
But all dairy has IGF1 in it. Think of what dairy does. Darius, the IGF1s in dairy along with the hormones in dairy, upregulate MTOR, why?
products are supposed to be for baby animals.
What do baby animals become?
Adult animals.
They do so by growing.
So, and the IGF, one of the hormones that are in it
help upregulate MTOR to help with growth.
That's the whole purpose of that.
So, we don't want to be growing cells
and increasing replication factors of cells
if we have a diagnosis of cancer.
So, you don't have to worry about getting a recumbent
bovine growth hormone because you're not going to be
eating much dairy.
So, but if you do eat dairy,
this is where you want to eat organic dairy
that does not have that.
So, if you're going to be eating dairy,
so if you're going to, the bodyweight protocol,
you want to be making sure you get
more organic cottage cheese because you don't
what are BGH in your cottage cheese that you are using
because even though you are falsified it with fat,
you are still getting that hormone.
So, that's not a good thing.
So, if you do eat any dairy,
make sure you're getting organic dairy
so you don't get that in there.
Liberty meat.
So, meat is going to have growth hormones in it
and IGF, what is that?
And that's why we do the meat.
Even the people that we allow to eat meat when we test them.
So, we don't let you to be this carnivorous carnivore
by any stretch of the imagination.
Just things like injury surgeries.
We've talked about this in the past.
When we injure, cut your hand someplace,
it's going to upregulate IGF one in order to heal that wound.
That's how your body heals that wound back to this chart here.
So, you have an injury, any cell damage for any kind.
This is where it says if you're going to do radiation treatment,
you're going to have cell damage,
you're going to upregulate M-tore.
That's how your body has to heal from any wound
is an opregulation of M-tore.
Well, that's that opregulation of M-tores.
It's going to be just specific to that wound.
It's going to affect the cancer cells as well.
So, we want to avoid any surgeries
that we could possibly avoid.
And this is one reason why you would have to work out
like you're trading for a marathon
where you have cancer because you aren't doing
microscopic injury to muscle and ligament damage constantly.
And you're going to be upregulated IGF one,
constantly to heal from that really tough workout
you had last week.
Excess body weight, excess glucose, sugar consumption,
insulin sensitivity is all going to increase IGF one.
And when you increase IGF one,
we decrease apoptosis.
We decrease cell deaths.
We decrease our ability to kill cancer cells.
We also increase the risk of metastasis.
We increase cancer growth.
We increase angiogenesis, new blood vessel growth
into a heart tumor, which is not good.
So, what do we want to do?
We want to try to stay away from these things, right?
That'd be one really good thing.
We want to decrease sugar consumption.
Decreasing sugar consumption will help lower IGF one levels.
Decrease meat, consider a more plant-based diet.
Even if your cancer isn't driven by amino acids
and it's okay to eat meat,
consider eating a higher vote of plant-based foods.
Obviously, no hormones stayed away from dairy.
Obviously, you don't take any of these stimulator supplements
like we talked about in this picture.
And taking vitamin D could help decrease IGF one levels.
Matter of fact, if you've had your IGF one levels tested
because you could test this through a blood test
and those blood levels are high,
it's a pretty good chance
that you're deficient in vitamin D
or you have vitamin D receptor gene defects.
So, when we look at your genes,
we will look at that as well.
Consider lowering calorie intake
or doing a fasting mimicky diet.
Call back to the fasting mimicky diet videos that I made.
This could be very helpful.
This is one of the things that is so,
so beneficial about the fasting mimicky diet
is that it lowers IGF one levels.
So, and having low IGF one levels
is essential for cancer patients.
Consider you using resveratrol.
No, resveratrol is a great anti-aging supplement
but it's really good for cancer.
The negative about resveratrol has such a short half-life.
So, you have to take it throughout the day.
Three to five times a day,
you have to take resveratrol.
If you're gonna be taking resveratrol,
if you only take it once a day has a half-life
of only about five to 15 minutes,
believe it or not.
So, it decreases quite quickly.
Curcumin is a great thing to take
for just about everything, inflammation, IGF one levels.
What we learned about back here in the slides before
your NF-campus beta levels, it decreases that.
Curcumin is great for cancer as well
but you really want to be up to,
you want a good curcumin first of all
like the curcuclear that we have
which is the tetrahedral curcumin form of the curcumin.
That's the form that we use in the curcuclear capsule.
So, that's also the form that's in the sun spectrum.
So, the greater, you want curcumin up to levels
three to five grams, three to six grams a day.
Probiotics, your probiotics are in your sun spectrum
but consider taking extra probiotics
at a fairly regular basis.
If not, the daily basis does necessarily need to be daily.
Consider taking extra probiotics and switching brands around.
So, you're getting different strains.
Zig can help also decrease IGF one levels.
Bilk thistle also can help decrease IGF one.
Bilk thistles also we use for the liver.
So good for the liver.
So consider those things.
Other questions that we had come in.
Can you use a binder, use as a binder
the bosa, pubica seed for toxins
also to clear infections and dormant viruses?
So, the bosa is a great product.
We use it a lot for our Lyme patients.
Not so much for our cancer patients.
It tends to work really good for funguses.
Fung guy, viruses, some dormant bacteria
that are hard to get.
The bosa is a good product to pull that out.
Here's they come in a powder and that's when our bosa
as we sell it at the store right here.
And it can work well for those kind of things, yes.
Does it interfere with cancer?
I haven't read anything on bosa with cancer
but it certainly doesn't interfere with anything
you're taking with that.
And then if you're trying to kill viruses and bacteria
and different types of fungi and stuff,
the question was should she stagger the kill programs?
I noticed there, she said I noticed
there are some kill programs in my overnight sense.
Haka while I still have the fungus,
fungus and bacteria and molded viruses
are very difficult to kill.
And they tend to morph their frequencies quite quickly.
That's how they stay alive in their environment.
They're always changing.
The reason why they're hard is because they have
such a fast replication time and they're living organisms.
So they are changing their morphine themselves
in order to stay alive.
And if you really want to get into
how live stays alive and stuff read by live books
that I go into greater detail with that.
But you almost have to do sweet programs
to kill different viruses and fungus.
So if you have a stubborn virus or fungus
or something like that, you have to let us know
that we can write a sweet program for you
that can be more beneficial.
Use of turmeric mixed with coconut oil.
The skin is that good for you.
Can it be beneficial?
How's the absorption?
Would you don't use any pepper with it?
Well, you use pepper to increase the half life of turmeric.
And you only do that, orally.
And you only do that if you're taking
the whole spice turmeric.
If you're taking the tetrahydrocriminoid
like in curcuclear, you don't need to use the pepper anymore
because you're taking the most bioavailable form
and you don't need to use the pepper.
But using turmeric just as it's the ground spice
mixed with an oil of any kind, in this case,
this person is using coconut oil on your skin.
Are you absorbing it?
Yes, you are absorbing it.
All of it, though you won't.
The negative of doing this is the ground spice
is a yellow color, orange color.
And you're going to make your skin look all orange
and you're going to be perfect for Halloween.
And they give me, but BL and that,
you're going to look like, you just like something's,
you're very ill.
So if you're using it at a spot to kill
like a basal cell cancer or something like that,
that's understandable.
But if you're going to spit it all over your skin
for something that you're going to,
it's not going to be very, very good looking.
We are in the process of possibly getting
the straight tetrahedral curcuminoid product,
which is actually not an orange product.
It's a white product as a powder,
but we have to find out with a supplier if you could get it
because when I tried to get it directly from the supplier,
I had to order like a pallet of it.
But I do have another supplier
that will sell me some of his product
that's used in one of our products that we're making.
So I might be able to get the clear,
or it's a clear, it's a white product.
So that mixed with an oil to use as a topical skin product
that you will be turning your skin orange.
But we have thought that we've used it as with a cream
with the MSO also, and it's worked really well,
but you'll still get that skin discoloration
when you use just the ground turmeric.
Do oils negatively affect sweating.
I don't believe so, no.
I don't think you're clogging your sweat pores
when you're putting the oils on there.
So if you were using an oil with an aluminum
or a heavy metal in there like your antiperspirates,
then the whole purpose of using an aluminum
in an antiperspirate is to clog your sweat pores
so that you don't sweat.
That's not good, so.
But if you're just using coconut oil
or you're using a shade butter or something natural like that,
no, I don't think you're affecting your sweat glands
and you're not affecting sweating at all.
Using DMSO over an involved lymph node,
yes, that could be very beneficial.
You could also use DMSO as a driver.
Typically, we use DMSO as a driver.
So DMSO is diabetal cell foxide,
which is a product that is quickly and readily absorbed.
Using too much DMSO,
because when it was a big fan back in the 1970s,
people could get sick from it.
Especially if you have defects on your CBS pathway,
you could get sick because it isn't sulfur product.
And if you have CBS defects,
you don't detox sulfur very well.
So that could be a problem.
But it was really only a problem
when people thought it was the cure-all for everything
and they dumped their hands in it,
soaked their bodies in the stuff.
And you're probably getting too much,
even if you don't have those defects.
And people would literally smell like garlic or sulfur.
But used sparingly, as we do with the DMSO zig spray,
it could be very beneficial to help kill a cancer
or stop a cancer from growing.
So DMSO by itself is an anti-inflammatory.
When you couple it with something that you want
to get into the tissue,
then it could be a driver,
it could be a carrier of that thing.
So often you go back and watch by videos on zig-encancer,
ways to get sick in a tuber can be the using DMSO.
So that could be a good driver.
Okay, so we are going to open it up for questions
and I am unmuted everybody.
I will ask that if you have,
on the last few weeks, if you've been on the call
and you've asked a question,
I ask that if you'll please refrain tonight
because we want to get other people involved,
if it's all possible,
and other people to get a chance to ask questions.
So it's the floor is yours.
Dr. Connors, I have a question concerning the meat.
Yep.
We raise our own beef, we have our own hay,
and so we don't inject our animals with anything.
Because if that's still a problem,
if I eat meat being on a keto diet,
that's primarily, you know,
I eat meat once a day at least.
Yep.
So if you're going to eat,
if you're on a keto diet,
you're going to be eating meat constantly.
And then your source is so important.
So you're still going to get an IGF1 from your meat,
but you're going to get a lot less,
you're not going to get a great growth hormones
that they're feeding in the meat.
So yeah, that's the way to do it.
Even on a keto diet, you know,
you know, go a day without meat,
you don't have to necessarily eat every day.
But the biggest thing is that, you know,
some people out of keto diet,
they think that that's pretty great,
but then eat meat five times a day,
and you're not doing that.
So you're safe on that.
Great. Thank you so much.
Any other questions?
But Dr. Conner, this is the chef,
I have a question that I've asked questions other week.
Go ahead.
It's sour, sour, sour,
so, so, so P.
Yeah.
It's a fruit that comes from Australia.
It's been very effective.
And I think there's sour,
so leaves make tea.
Do you know that if it's,
you know anything about it?
I've read about it.
It's hard to get,
but it's certainly anything like that.
Anything like that is worth a try.
With anything that you're buying,
what you have to be careful of is purity.
I'll give you an example.
So one product that's really hot on the market,
not so much with cancer,
but with autoimmune patients is a pot,
you know,
we, I think we,
I might even have a cancer patient that's taking creative.
You may have heard of it,
you may not have heard of it,
but I don't think there's a lot of information around the cancer
circles for creative,
but with autoimmune patients,
it's really big.
You have to be not technically illegal in the United States.
You have to order it from overseas.
We had a friend who went to a friend's house and said,
I got this great tea because it can be a little,
I got to mute everybody while I answer this.
It can be a little hallucinogenic in a way.
It could give you a sense of ease and calmness.
It's really great for anxiety patients.
So that's the big push for it right now,
but the purity is a huge issue.
Well, this friend that went over to his body's house and had some.
He had to end up going to the emergency room and he almost died.
So it can be very dangerous.
So I would just be careful on purity because you buy something from China.
You know, how do you know if it's pure or not?
So that's the only thing that I would be careful with with some of the products
that you could buy.
Now, if you buy something that is labeled and it's sold by a major distributor in the United States,
that it's probably safe as far as not going to be toxic,
but there's no guarantee that it actually has eaten what it says it's in it.
It might be 95% ground rice.
And that's just the risk that you take the old.
I guess that isn't a negative in a sense that nobody's going to get hurt from it.
But it's a negative in a sense that you're not going to necessarily be help from it.
So that's the difficult part of buying products that that you don't have a lab that's tested it.
So I'm all for it.
If you could get it from a reputable source.
On the sour shop, I was told that whole food had it.
I called them and I'm going to call back and talk to their buyer.
And I'll find out from him.
If you could post it on Facebook, that would be good information for everybody.
I will. Thank you.
The other.
I want to.
Is maximum amount of foot baths.
I could do it.
Things like.
When I'm doing foot baths, it's pulling a lot out of my body every time.
I mean, I feel fabulous afterwards.
Only hesitation on foot baths is it will pull minerals.
So as long as you are getting minerals in your body, then I'm not worried about that.
Just like doing sound as, oh, I want to do a soda.
You know, twice a day, I feel so much better.
I'm all for it. Go for a soda twice a day.
But make sure you replenish it your minerals.
So how do you replenish your bills?
You could take a mineral supplement.
Again, go back to what type of mineral supplement should I take?
It should be a, it should be a mineral supplement that is either plant based,
which should be like maybe drink another greens drink.
That would be a good source of replenishing those electrolytes and minerals.
You could take some, you know, make sure you go back to salting your food with good Himalayan or sea salt,
natural sea salt, or take a mineral supplement, like the one that we have that is a glycine double boat,
double-bited carbon bond glycine product.
But I do have a video on correct supplements to take.
If you take a good food based supplement that, that you're going to be fighting,
you could do a couple of day if you wanted to.
That would be just fun.
Thank you so much.
I just want to personally thank you.
I was able to listen to some of your recent videos and related to every single thing you said being a nurse for over 50 years.
I, I, I was very touched and that it was beautiful.
And thank you so much.
Oh, you're very welcome.
I just want to know how you became a nurse when you were six years old.
I mean, if you were a nurse in 50 years, that's just amazing.
But.
You're lovely.
Thank you.
I'm seven, actually, 76.
Oh, my guys.
Yeah.
Old lady.
When you lose your hair from chemo and you, and you have a carry away, you, you look a little younger, maybe.
Well, that's great.
You look very.
Well, my, here's my new word.
Stay positive, stay strong.
That's great.
We all need that.
Well, thank you, Liz.
Well, I just hope you know how dearly you are loved and deeply appreciated.
Because the information that you gave me on protocol, you know, on, it works.
It works.
It's just wonderful.
Well, let's just keep it up right and keep our prayer lighted order and everybody praying for each other.
That's the most important thing.
Absolutely.
Jeremiah 29, 11 to 14.
There it is.
That's always been.
All right.
Any other questions?
No.
All right.
Well, we can call it a day if you guys have any questions that you're afraid to ask.
Make sure you email them to you to be sorry.
And for our new people that are on this for the first time or so that have not or listening to this for the first time or so.
If you have questions that you don't want to state them on live call or you can't hear the live calls.
Email questions, but please put in the memo light on the email.
Zoom question because we get about 150 emails a day and we don't want it to get lost.
So thank you very much.
This will be recorded.
Thank you so much.
Somebody's hand raised.
Go ahead.
You have a question.
No.
Well, this will be this will be recorded and placed on Facebook.
So thanks so much and we will talk again very soon.
Thank you.
Okay.
Bye bye.
Thank you.